my producer is trying to get my  attention is that for sure  really this is crazy right now that's  insane  ladies and gentlemen this is amazing of  course we're all familiar with Aquaman  right okay yeah  I've just been told it's not I just been  told that Aquaman is about to spawn  right here  he's decided to do it right there okay  there is bears Aquaman king of the seven  seas monarch of the oceans she's  swimming around making sure the area is  safe for his mate this is fascinating  and here comes aqua woman woman here she  comes  she is clearly swollen with eggs lady  good after a brief courtship ritual  where they just sort of look at each  other and have a courtship ritual she  releases her eggs onto the sea floor  while Aquaman stands guard there she  goes  the eggs have been released and now it's  Aquaman's turn he hovers over the eggs  I said he hovers over the edge and  carefully deposits his awkward sperm  [Applause]  there you have it  [Applause]